التطورات متلاحقه في مناطق عده من قطاع
غزه سنبدا من المنطقه الجنوبيه التي تشهد
قتال ضاري ومستمر في اكثر من نقطه واكثر
من منطقه سنبدا في منطقه الجراره لسبب
بسيط القراره كان قد قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه انهى عملياته فيها اليوم القراره نقطه
اشتباكات قويه القوات الاسرائيليه تحاول
مجددا الدفع باليات الى داخل القراره
وكتائب القسام نفذت عده عمليات استهداف
لجنود ومدرعات وافراد من المشاد بالتزامن
مع ذلك تبقى مدينه خان يونس بطبيعه الحال
منطقه اشتباك اساسيه وكبيره الهجوم مستمر
على المدينه وهناك توغلات لكن الجديد ان
محاور القتال توسعت ب وتكثف القتال فيها
سواء جنوب مدينه خان يونس في منطقه معا او
في الشوارع المحيطه بالمدينه وهناك ايضا
بالتوغل الاسرائيليه داخل المدينه هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه وضاره وهناك استهدافات
الجيش الاسرائيلي او احد قاده الالويه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي التي تقاتل في جنوب في
يعني محافظه خانيونس كان تحدث امس عن ان
القوات المقاتله في الجنوب تحاول التعرف
اكثر على الطبيعه الميدانيه خاصه وانها
وان القتال يستمر في خان يونس وفي
المحافظه الجنوبيه منذ بضعه اسابيع فقط
على عكس ما هي حاله القتال في المناطق
الاخرى والكلام طبعا نقلته جيروزالم بوست
عن احد القاده العسكريين في جنوب قطاع غزه
نشير ايضا الى ان القوات الاسرائيليه على
موقعها على تطبيق اكس تحدثت اليوم ايضا عن
استهداف في شارع الرشيد الى ال الغرب من
قطاع غزه لم يشهد الكثير من ال القتال
الشارع الجنوبي هذا الشارع يربط المحافظه
الوسطى بالمحافظه الجنوبيه اليوم على
موقعه على اكس قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
اشتبه باحد المباني وهاجمها وبحسب ما يزعم
يقول انه وجد عتاد لقوات النخبه كما سماها
التابعه لحركه حماس وقال وحدد للواء خان
تونس في حركه حماس المحافظه الوسطى يشتعل
فيها القتال بشكل عنيف جدا الجديد لدينا
اليوم هو فتح محور جديد في الزوايده
الزوايده لم تكن الاشتباكات تجري فيها
كانت مناطق الاشتباكات تقتصر على نصيرات
البريج وايضا المغازي اليوم توسع القتال
وبتنا نتحدث عن اشتباكات ضاريه ومن مسافات
قريبه حتى في الزويده طبعا الزوايده عفوا
الزوايده لها
اهميه قوات الاحتلال كانت تحاول الدخول
الى مخيم البريج من الجانب الغربي تحيطه
من ثلاث جهات الشمال والشرق والجنوب وايضا
مخيم المغازي وتحاول التوغل الى عمق
المخيمين من المنطقه الغربيه لكن كانت
تهاجم من الخلف ولذلك وسعت هذه العمليات
لتشمل بلده الزوايده ضمن هذه العمليات
العسكريه التي تترافع ايضا مع قصف في
المناطق المحاذيه للشريط الحدودي و كما
نذكر دوما بان المشكله الكبرى لدى القوات
الاحتلال المتوغلة
في الجيش الاسرائيلي سرب للقناه الثان بان
الجيش يقاتل على اكثر من جبهه ميدانيه
وهناك جبهه سياسيه ربما هذا يفسر ما يمكن
ان نصفه بالارتباك الميداني الارتباك
الميداني وربما غياب استراتيجيه منسقه
ووحيده لشكل الهجمات المنطقه الشماليه قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ اكثر من عره ايام
انه انهى ما سماه بالاعمال العسكريه هناك
اليوم عادت الاجت بكات الى غرب منطقه
جباليا وغرب مخيم جباليا وعلما ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انه انسحب من التفاح
والدرج ومن غير المفهوم بعد ما اذا كانت
قوات الاحتلال تريد الدخول مجددا والتوغل
الى داخل جباليا ومخيم جباليا ومناطق اخرى
ام لا علما ان المدرعات
الاسرائيليه بقيت رغم انسحابها من التفاح
والدرج على سبيل المثال وهذا ما اعلنته هي
رغم ذلك تبقى او بقيت اليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي متمركزه في المنطقه الغربيه
قرابه الشواطئ مع البحر المتوسط وهناك
اليوم معلومات تقول بان الهجوم اليوم في
المناطق الشماليه والمناطق الوسطى يتم
باستخدام الاليات المدرعه والدبابات
والطائرات المسيره للمراقبه وطائرات مسيره
هجوميه وقناصه ايضا m